hello there video games and pop culture
go hand in hand it's the perfect place
to make a subtle joke to reward
eagle-eyed Gamers from Double Rainbows
all the way across the sky to a man
called Jeff yeah today we're looking at
60 memes and viral videos hidden in
video games like this iconic meme of
Sanic from top quality artist oxenhart
who showed us all how to draw the
fastest Hedgehog to ever live years
later that design was forever
immortalized as a t-shirt in Sonic
forces they embrace the meme and Sanic
is now legit back in 2015 a viral
phenomenon happened around address was
it golden white or was it blue and black
the internet lost its mind for a few
weeks as we all try to figure it out so
just cause put it to the test and
created two NPCs on a hotel balcony both
wearing the dress but did it help is
this image white and gold or blue and
black we'll let the comment decide I say
it's white and gold
some viral videos are just wholesome
like this one it takes a pad like no
problem that's a great cat right there
and to everyone's surprise Spider-Man
Miles Morales referenced this in a cut
scene it takes a pet like no problem
that's a great cat and it so happens
that this cat is also called Spider-Man
don't ask why it takes a pet like no
problem it takes a pet like no problem
one of the longest running memes is John
Cena You Can't See Me image it's
impossible to escape it hey I'm John
Cena I accidentally became a meme it
became so big that WWE 2k23 made it a
reality after completing John Cena's
campaign you'll unlock this his
character model is totally invisible all
we see is a floating pile of clothes and
of course there's some extra dialogue
from the commentators guys is my monitor
broken I don't see anything if only the
worthy can see him Saxton remember when
Keanu Reeves appeared at the Xbox E3
event in 2019 while describing cyberpunk
2077 this happened it's really going to
be breathtaking
your breathtaking this wholesome moment
became one of the most re-watched and
mimified events in video game history
and CD project red couldn't resist
adding the moment to the game thank you
thank you Carrie your breathtaking the
pose is pretty close too one of my
favorite viral videos showed an
overwhelmed dude watching a double
rainbow forming in the sky double
rainbow oh my God it's a double rainbow
all the way the noises that came out of
his mouth end up being so iconic it was
remixed into a song
we all waited to see who would be the
first video game to pay homage to this
and Borderlands 2 took up the mantle by
finding this lonely Campsite in the
highlands it's possible for Handsome
Jack or claptrap to reenact that scene
as two rainbows form in the distance
double rainbow
hold on all the way
picked up a rainbow all the way oh
what does it mean over in avatar The
Last Airbender a running joke that got
the meme treatment is for the Cabbage
Bender
images who would somehow always have his
cart of cabbages destroyed he quietly
made his way over to Baldur's Gate but
oh no it's happened again
should you be playing as a monk like Ong
there's some more dialogue stay clear of
our cabbages
you're sort of done enough damage as it
is
speaking of Baldur's Gate 3 larion
Studios have asked me to share some
information and a few thoughts on the
game because the Dungeons and dragon
style RPG is now available on
PlayStation 5. and don't worry you don't
need a mouse and keyboard here it plays
great on a controller Baldur's Gate 3
has some of the highest Metacritic
scores of all time and I honestly think
we are looking at the game of the year
right here in Baldur's Gate 3 we create
our own character including their
attributes I created this Barbarian
Beauty known as the deathbringer but
everything from sorcerer to Bard is here
it all comes down to who you want as the
center of your story and what play style
you prefer from there The World is Yours
to explore the direction of the
narrative is down to your decisions and
the Simplicity of a dice roll and play
your cards right it's possible to
romance characters too Baldur's Gate 3
can be played alone or if you prefer
team up with up to four players online
or even couch Co-op too be sure to click
the link in the description to start
your own Journey but remember stay clear
of our characters remember the days when
vine was a thing it was the home of
random comedy and anything at all could
go viral like this it is Wednesday my
dudes Jimmy he is inspired Wednesday
call became a meme starring a frog and a
Dev liked it so much and Easter egg was
created in postal brain damage by
hunting down and interacting with the
Frog this will happen
those moronic developers thought they
could hide this from me
we forgot one important step it has to
be a Wednesday try again it is Wednesday
my dude
[Music]
a dance party remix begins and this all
started with a dude in Spider-Man
cosplay hyping up Wednesdays over in Red
Dead Redemption 2 it's possible to find
this location which holds a scary secret
take the time to look around and you'll
find a donkey pulling a mill wheel but
that's not a donkey it's a woman and she
is no longer in the land of the living
the inclusion of the donkey lady has a
little bit of history as a glitch back
in the original Red Dead Redemption
could turn NPCs into donkeys the donkey
lady became folklore thanks to a viral
video and Rockstar Games gave it the
Easter egg it deserved sadly she didn't
survive but now you can rest donkey lady
over to fortnite now and a paper plane
glider was added to the start with
scribble notes all over it like a school
textbook we didn't notice right away but
look close enough and under the wing
you'll see this my name's Jeff my name
is Jeff because 22 Jump Street happened
and you could not avoid that Meme yeah
another inescapable meme was potato
Jesus and Hitman added it to their World
hidden in plain sight at Sapienza on the
wall of the church is potato Jesus and
later in the series over in Berlin a
criminal gang have started away the
story behind this was that an artist
attempted to restore a very old image of
Jesus called behold the man and well she
ruined the image completely and
destroyed a very expensive piece of
artwork an ongoing meme in Rainbow Six
Siege is all about tachanko due to how
useless he was in the early days he
gained a cult following dubbing him Lord
tachenka and now regular not to that can
be found in the game whether it's an
inconspicuous block of rock that can be
pummeled into his likeness or something
way bigger over at the stadium look out
for these RC Vents and at the bottom is
a giant Stone version of that Legend
carved like the Greek god he should be
the Sonic the Hedgehog Twitter account
loves to spread memes and in 2015 there
was this strange Trend to add and
Knuckles to the end of things and things
just kept getting out of hand when Deus
Ex mankind divided released it was
possible to search nearby game stars to
find by the year 2029 there really will
be a game called Knuckles Knuckles and
Knuckles and Knuckles for sale 2029
can't come soon enough and we can't get
through an Easter egg video without a
bit of SpongeBob SquarePants in battle 4
Bikini Bottom rehydrated be sure to
visit this section of the jellyfish
caves to find the Primitive SpongeBob
Meme painted on the wall oh in fact the
less we say about this one the better
the initial reveal of Halo infinite
somehow became all about a brute the
internet dubbed Craig by pausing the
fast-flowing gameplay we were left with
this image and the internet did their
thing and memed the hell out of it in
the final game it's possible to climb to
this spot and look around and you'll
find Craig The Brute is a musician and
he has an album too with many songs on
it like the day you became a meme now
that is how you Embrace a meme back over
to Just Cause 3 and another meme Easter
egg found by tipping area in masos is a
small dog we can help get him all the
way to his kennel and you'll unlock Doge
mode in the settings now every time Rico
does something he'll get the doge meme
template from 2013. I never understood
this one so I'll let somebody else
explain let's just say there's a heavy
emphasis on the words much very so such
and many written in broken English as if
the animal is speaking to himself in his
head
so there's another nine minutes of your
life wasted with memes and viral videos
thanks for watching oh and a huge thanks
to larion Studios for sponsoring today's
video check out the link in the video
description below and it'll take you to
the wonderful world of Baldur's Gate 3
on Console see ya
[Music]